- But you've recently had to deal
with your own bullies, right, online?
- Yeah, I had a nude photo leaked.
- Like how nude?
What are we talking about here?
- Well first of all, let
me just tell you something.
It wasn't that bad.
- First of all, if I had your body,
I'd almost leak it myself.
(laughing)
- I have to say, I was
actually way more embarrassed
about all the screen grabs
of inspirational quotes
that I had in my phone.
(laughing)
I was like, please don't release those!
- You do need therapy!
No, it's actually my own fault.
I was doing Instagram Stories one night,
and weed is now legal in California,
(audience applause)
which is not a good mix,
don't clap for that!
(audience laughing)
And so I had done, and it
kinda slipped a little,
and I posted it by accident,
and then a bunch of people were like,
"Oh my God, your boob is on Instagram!"
and then I deleted it, so they
had just done a screen grab,
and then later they said like,
"How much money for us to not post this?"
And I was like, "I'm
not giving you my money,
I've worked too hard."
- And my boob looks great!
- And you know what,
(laughing)
I paid good money for these.
I'm proud of them.
- So you respect them!
- But I was annoyed cause I was like,
here's better nude photos of me!
I mean, it's down, I'm in the bathtub,
I look like I'm having a home birth.
Like it's not--
(laughing)
- Oh no!
- I'm like (strangled grunting)
like in a tub of water.
So it's not--
- And you're high, so you're
thinkin' "I look awesome".
(laughing)
"I look amazing.
This is the best anyone's ever seen me."
- I'm like holding a
sponge, it's very odd.
(laughing)
- But that's awesome and smart of you.
You ended up putting it
out, cause you were like,
"You ain't gettin' the money,
if anybody's gettin' paid
for my boob, it's me."
- It's gonna be me, okay?
- So I just took the
bargaining chip off the table,
is the only thing I knew how to do.
- So I was like, I'm
just gonna post it myself
- That's amazing.
And we'll see.
- It's a boob.
- It's a boob!
- You can see that
sometimes at restaurants
when people are nursing.
It's a boob, it's fine.